please help me my arm is literally
stopping trying to grab something at the
bottom
just pull it out please help me but just
maybe show you something oh here just
use the soap just use a soap grab help
can you please pull it out
no i didn't just pull it out
wait
[Laughter]
hi guys i'm eileen i'm devin
and this is how going viral changed our
lives
[Music]
my first viral video was kind of like a
spur of the moment kind of thing i think
it was like 3 a.m that i posted it at i
didn't really think anything of it there
was a trend in the beginning of
quarantine where like girls were
recording themselves dancing but it
would actually be recording the other
person like their dad their boyfriend or
stuff like that and i was like you know
what i'll try it with devin so i tried
it and i was like hey i'll post it and
then i woke up in the morning and my
phone was blowing up and i was so
shocked i woke up and i had like 100k
views i was like oh my god like what
like my video just went viral and he was
like half asleep so
he probably thought his dream was like
nice
i wish they saw your dance moves though
because you were killing it oh my god
i'm i'm such a bad down sarah i'm a man
i'm not a good tic-tock dancer hmm what
did it do
i don't i think it did so well because
he's just like really supportive and i
think
no i'm not
what were you doing before i took top i
was working on a cell phone company
i was standing up for a long time i
think i would have had some back
problems
juxtaposed your body detoxing my body
thank you i was working at auritzia at
the time i was working pretty much full
time all the time we actually worked
together for two days yeah at eritsia
and i hated it yeah he's not a retail oh
what she was bossing me around
why are you going so slow
it's my first day
not a good employee
now we work together by the way devin
does have his own tick tock account now
so do you want to share
one of your favorite videos
i'm plugging you
maybe the ones that are you're in i
don't know just like the ones we uh the
ones we make together i really like the
one where like you were like oh reasons
why my girlfriend is mad at me oh
favorite video oh yeah that was really
funny you want to check that out that
has some truth to it that one's from the
heart
i'm sure a lot of people can relate
rock he would absolutely be our dream
collab yeah yeah we love him he's
hilarious i love how he's
himself and he doesn't care about anyone
else's opinion which i definitely need
to work on but that is my dream collab
bretman if you're watching this
i love you
i just went on a brand my very first
round trip i
cried so much i couldn't believe it was
my real life but i won a round trip and
i just had the best time
meeting everyone oh my god i met so many
cool people and we just like had such
nice conversations and also speaking of
bretman rock he also comments on our
videos
so that's always really cool because i
love him
i saw her and i was like
damn
i knew when i saw her i was like she's
hella
hella short
but she pretty but i was like yo i like
i like her and then we started hanging
out more through
weird circumstances i didn't even
initiate it we just started hanging out
more through like mutual friends and
stuff yeah something was like pulling us
together right
her cousin
had a
cotillion so
yeah filipinos you know what this is
it's like a dance yeah when they turn 18
and they do a dance number a partner
dance they asked me last minute because
someone backed out but
we talked a lot during that practice and
stuff and she wanted to always leave
okay okay
you're so cute
but she did it as a joke uh-huh but it
made my heart pound you started normal
from there like we started talking more
and then
i had a thing with another girl and then
she was like oh maybe i should stop
doing those jokes like you know tell me
i'm like
no don't do that
and then lo and behold here we are nine
years later here we are nine years later
that was when we were 16 year old
i think the most memorable time is we
went to um this little kind of like fair
thing that was happening
yeah in our city and we were just
getting recognized and recognized photos
after photos and it was like such like
it's so crazy because i think that
people are scared to come up with us
because they think that we don't enjoy
you know talking to people but we
absolutely loved it it was so fun
meeting everyone who like supports us
and it's so crazy
to put faces behind all the people that
support us so it was really memorable
you guys are dope just come up to us say
hi we're probably more shyer than you
yeah
special projects coming up uh yes i
would actually like to
take this opportunity to plug my twitch
twitch.tv
and chris i will start streaming and we
are
doing a
collab streaming as well
uh twitch.tv slash eileen and devin yeah
and we're gonna be doing a lot of events
on there for charity so that would be
very fun and exciting to do because yeah
get to do what we love and give back yes
we're all about giving back we have
goals but we just like don't have set
how to reach yeah we just we will yeah
we definitely want to travel more i
think that's like a huge goal of ours
we will world more oh yeah we will we
will travel more see the world meet new
friends like expand our
social media presence you know okay yeah
we have some goals we've got some goals
we just don't know how we're gonna go
about that
well we got goals
okay well we had so much fun and thank
you for asking us these questions we
absolutely love you guys don't forget to
check out our social media adam
christine and
devin chris
amazing and our youtube channel eileen
and hi we love you guys oh yeah don't
forget our merch
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you